this is what happens to a normally
bustling City Center when public sector
workers stay at home in Northern
irelanders elsewhere it is the public
sector that keeps the wheels of the
economy
[Applause]
turning and here as elsewhere High
inflation and a cost of living crisis
have put pressure on public sector pay
but this being Northern Ireland there is
a political crisis as well devolved
government in the storm on assembly that
hasn't functioned for almost 2 years the
Democratic unionist Party Walked Out in
protest at Post brexit Trading
arrangements and despite cajoling by the
government in London including
withholding billions of dollars in
financial incentives that could be used
to pay higher wages the dup refuses to
rejoin this is a campaign we will
continue this is a campaign we will win
the workers increasingly angry are
caught in the middle what we need here
is the British government to release the
money which they've indicated is
available which they are withholding as
a means to lever the Democratic unionist
party back into the executive instor
workers are completely Fed Up and
frustrated this is the consequence of
political paralysis public sector
workers who've toiled away without a pay
rise because there's no devolved
government with a budget to give them
one they say here that they porns in a
game
Northern Ireland is often held up as a
working example of Peace building and
power sharing but the formal structures
set up under the Good Friday peace
agreement that ended Decades of conflict
hardly work at
all together with the public sector
among those paying the price Jonah Hall
Al jazer
Belfast make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer